was geht hier ist euer max und herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video wir
spielen minecraft jump league aber nicht
irgendwie sondern die super secret
settings challenge ein bisschen schiss
davor ich bin wirklich nicht gut in jump
run und bin auch keiner der irgendwie
wie mein bruder der ist die absolute
profi im spielmodus der das schon mal
gesucht der tat es sind bei mir andere
spielmodi dich halt mal intensiver
gezockt habe sage ich mal
und deshalb habe ich ziemlich angst dass
sich in die schwereren module kommen
einfach untergehen werde jetzt am anfang
behaupte ich mal geht alles noch
einigermaßen aber wenn es anders wäre
dann wäre auch nur peinlich wenn ich
dann die ganze zeit runter falle dann
wird das ziemlich dumm und es geht los
ok super-sieg setting ein ok sehr nice
das damit kann man auf jeden fall leben
ich hatte euch auf twitter gefragt was
hier mit super series super secret
settings sehen wollt und ok ist und die
mehrheit von euch hatte gesagt jump
league auf jeden fall und deshalb was
ist das denn
okay leute so wird das nicht so mein
gott was ist das die mehrheit von ruhig
hatte jump league gesagt und deshalb
haben wir das gemacht haben dass ihr
schon mal in gestern gemacht aber ich
glaube dass die klassische variante ist
auch gott alter wenn ich jetzt hier
schon hänge was zur hölle soll das wären
da wurde sie ja mehr oder weniger
erfunden die challenge um ein gott leute
es tut mir so leid schockeffekt
minecraft gehen schon die effekte aus so
oft völlig einfach an dieser echt
leichten stelle gerade eben habe ich
schon mal ein fehlversuch gehabt und das
klappt perfekt okay
da ich das jetzt weg machen ich würde
sagen nein zu gott sagt ok piste liegt
die sehen alle so weit weg aus die
blöcke also okay och nö war es auch das
war soul cent ist es schwarz weißer
sieht man gar nichts
leute das ist echt hart gerade für so
ein jump'n'run ludwig homann ich mal
einfach die ganze zeit den gleichen
fehler ok magazin cnet com
das können wir schaffen so können wir es
schaffen es tut mir wirklich leid leute
ich werde so dermaßen unter
ok damit den lsb fehler drin nein was
mache ich falsch
fuchs ich muss auch noch wechseln kann
man vergessen
wenn ich das jetzt kopfüber schaffe dann
gebe ich euch allen ein eis aus
die sehe
innerhalb der nächsten fünf minuten h
okay natürlich auch kommt schon leute
diese superstars settings verdammt nah
bei mir schlafen schon alle im haus
deshalb habe ich mich gerade
zusammenreißen müssen es ist echt
unglaublich
tut mir leid an diejenigen von euch die
jump run spielen können ich fühle mich
gerade wirklich schlechte dinge so
kannst du das hochladen oder werden die
die leute die das drauf haben dermaßen
den arsch aufreißen dafür dass du diese
kaka nicht hinkriegt ich behaupte jetzt
mal wirklich dass es zumindest zum teil
an den super settings liegt
was ist das denn wird auch komm schon
man es geht einfach nicht ja ich habe
für und sprung geschafft der eigentlich
übels leicht ist ich mein ich hab das ja
nun auch schon gespielt und da lief das
eigentlich auch schon immer und jetzt
bei dieser challenge endlich ist es
vorbei jetzt bei dieser challenge
verpacke ich so dermaßen ist wirklich
kann es mir eigentlich nur so erklären
dass der durch dass die abstände immer
so komplett unterschiedlich sind und so
was dass ich es einfach nicht gebacken
kriegen also okay das war jetzt wirklich
wieder leichter ist die kiste im haus
drin
ach verdammt ich habe die tür nicht
gesehen beschlüsse ändern okay das ist
auch schon wieder einigermaßen
erträglich im vergleich zu dem rest ok
sehr gut wie quit mäßig na ja geht das
schon deutlich besser eigentlich geht es
war ziemlich klar dass hierunter fallen
würde wir haben relativ guten effekt sag
ich mal
naja da wir hier in relativ glücklich
darüber irgendwie ist das absolut die
hölle für mich muss ich hier durch hey
gehen jetzt nicht runterziehen eis schon
wieder den ich sehe es schon vor mir wie
ich gerostet werde night vision dass sie
voll cool aus aber das ändert das echo
wie das macht auch noch mal krass
schwierig so lange muss ich den hut ohne
15 darf man nicht mal tut mir leid was
okay ich habe es geschafft hierdurch
wenn ich das jetzt mit diesem mega
komischen effekt schaffe bin ich voll
stolz auf mich
okay aber ich habe den weg jetzt
gefunden es war also richtig und es ist
einfach unfair kein effekt drin und ich
fall direkt runter sei doch einfach froh
nach festhaus max da hat sie sogar meine
stimme entschieden abzuhauen zukommt du
machst das jetzt du machst das jetzt
eine kiste muss ich mir wenigstens noch
gern nennen also ich glaube ich habe
mich schon häufig entschieden und die
leute die es schlimm finden haben wir
hier schon abgeschaltet also werde ich
probieren das so ein bisschen zu
hinterlassen ob gott jetzt habe ich die
kante überhaupt gesehen
diese ganzen leute die das irgendwie mit
beinahe null fehlern schaffen hält rudi
spielen das auch nicht mit super
settings aber das ist ja die absolute
hölle wo man es ist doch so ist bringt
mich gerade echt ein bisschen an die
verzweiflung dass sich das einfach nicht
hinkriege geht vorsichtig sprengen
vorsichtig spring habe ich gesagt dass
die schon wieder sagt seht ihr so läuft
man hierdurch zu machen dass die bros
kann wird jemand finnischen ich will
einfach nur von meinem leid erlöst
werden
wie schrecklich ich bin gerade ich bin
beim modul 5 des fedpol dieser sättigung
felder finde ich irgendwie meinem
normalen minecraft 1
kann ich mit noch ein paar mal sterben
dass ich mit wenigstens mit einem
vernünftigen effekt ins match kommen das
weiß ich genau dieses kopfüber ding das
ist glaube ich es ist nicht bloß
kopfüber sondern es ist die steuerung
komplett invertiert alter
ich bin besser als sonst das war keine
absicht
ok bisschen equipment mit dem bisschen
was wir hier am start haben
das wird nichts leute oh mein gott ey
einigen ohne ob tief ein und so was ich
kann überhaupt nicht sehen was die leute
für rüstung haben was ist das okay ich
glaube die hatten eisen schwert wir
machen ja extrem gut damit aber hab ich
halt nur zweimal getroffen bin ein typ
haben wir also bekommen ich muss sagen
nach jedem kilo nach jedem tod stelle
ich noch mal um so 7 hat absolut nichts
aber wen überrascht
okay da ist der gegner anscheinend leute
man sieht einfach nur so ein ding
christoph k ok können gerne und gut hat
jetzt nicht zu extrem gutes obstjahr
verdammt von mir leid dass mit f5 ich
muss mich halt irgendwie auch umschauen
also das ist schon relativ schwierig ich
habe die zeit in mein bruder für seinen
kanal aufgenommen sagt okay wir nehmen
uns den typen voran
soviel zum open den wir uns nehmen
nächsten gegner aussuchen
das sieht aus wie mit den verrücktesten
hacks spielen aber in wirklichkeit ist
es einfach nur ein unglaublich
abgefuckte super setting und ich darf
jetzt nicht sterben konnte kommt stück
um stück der kameraden die sg
konzentrationszone raus
nice den typ mig zyklus setting ändern
oder ich kann jetzt anhand von fünf
pixeln oder so was raten was man gegner
wahrscheinlich für eine rüstung an hat
ich will mir grad gar nicht mehr so
sicher welche karte wir spielen also
welche das management cockpit habt ihr
gesehen leute habt ihr gesehen bekommt
schon kuschelig es macht mich so
verrückt ich muss einfach auf diese
krise legen pixel gucken und hoffnung
dass ich irgendwas reise ja das war
schon mal nicht der fall wo es direkt so
traurig so okay ich bin jetzt einfach
meine musik weil ich so schlecht bin sie
einzufügen
da ist ein gegner da ist ein gegner
können jetzt schnappen
er hat den typen hat jedoch schon mal
oder aber hatte der uns dargelegt oder
die ihn verdammt ich bin so verdammt ich
bin realist im fall spaß leute das war
wirklich krass ich hab ein jump'n'run
gefällt ich habe die abgefuckte ssten
effekte im deathmatch gehabt aber jetzt
bin ich frei hat euch gefallen dann las
man leichter und des lebens einfach noch
nicht mal wieder macht's gut
bis dahin tschüss